[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever I'm gonna
[ __ ] nail it it's better that you
didn't it's better okay did you know
it's cultural corporation or where Asian
stuff like that okay first of all you
don't know if I have any agent in me so
I I don't care if it's one percent I get
to do it I just don't have freckles the
way you do okay first of all every Asian
in the world first of all you said first
of all twice already so it's second ball
how about this remember be okay you have
a scene every Asian in the world yeah
seeing everyone so you don't know that
for sure
Irish a black I have no agent yeah is it
weird that I feel like I've seen every
agent in the world
no that's just racist no I see that's
that culture appropriation have you been
to Tokyo have you seen how hip-hop
influences damn near everything over
there you know they took cholo culture
to do you think they do it it's only the
biggest appropriate is stealing Japanese
that guy have you guys ever been to
Mardi Gras at New Orleans yes I think
there's some appropriation happening
what do I put my finger on it you see
all the beads all there's all the
different things all the parades your
titties in a CD showing some look
cultures TT showing I don't know but
there's a part something how do you know
that it's not that they didn't create
their culture look I'm just try to be
more walking I mean that's true there's
got to be some stealing going on yeah
don't start by tagging probably the most
just poor predict dis poor Pete what's
the worst proportion this grace is it
race them [ __ ] it let's don't start with
black pigs [ __ ] ridiculous word it's
a ridiculous word what disproportionate
yeah it was
understand I just wanted to quit life
just in that one mother right there for
the words a lot guys
poor [ __ ] with me thank you
but like just talking about big syllable
words outside yes I have a new show I'm
working on and it's called big syllable
words now this wording is hard oh can I
be honest yes I work hard and is just I
[ __ ] up so many words and I know it's
right here for a new show I know so I
know so are you bailing stomach sleep
yes I speak okay that could work
yeah this is my first language yes I
know like five different dialects a
[ __ ] because New York to the song well
yes yes cow that has so yeah so SoCal
and NorCal that's two different dialects
without know what you probably updated
like hella this is it's crazy broke me
40 jobs yeah so do you like East Coast
you got less closing out the Midwest so
you got to know that I know that [ __ ] is
wild corner said I said it's buck its
it's dead yo which is dead well that's
what they done I was feeling bad for it
thank you thoughts and prayers for it
why are you really yeah Steve look at me
always always always a good did you lose
weight
thank you yeah you noticed yeah I bet
you just cut you're here i I went easy
on the sodium don't you know that's
pretty bad for you really doesn't know I
don't do sugar no sugar so what some
people can whole wait no right water
yeah close watery okay alright yeah
alright you look good I was like oh it
looks like you lost weight you went mmm
like he's like tasty I'm not like tase
me I was like look at see you looking
good I mean if I was like gay he's still
would be my type okay see [ __ ] well if
you are get what is your type I don't
know I've never even like
anyone here maybe barf hey I'll go for
your man man what you gonna do you'd win
yeah yeah I would want to like I was
always thinking about like I feel like
if you were in an interrogation room
like just did the whole bad cop good cop
thing right if you really want somebody
to talk in interrogation where like get
the buffest most wet guy in jail what
like like just grease the Vaseline all
over the curse yeah right it just have
him coming interrogation room like sauce
you don't tell me what I want to know
you'll be locked up with toss tonight
and he just starts stroking this don't
please don't tell me you're gonna get
tired one way or the other
don't think I could [ __ ] work huh
I don't think you would not be doing a
[ __ ] if Bart was your guy what's
probably part no no I just think it's
you sweaty he doesn't sweat no offense
again you would not you will not be
doing the [ __ ] you would be getting
[ __ ] or if you were [ __ ] apart know
it oh yeah no you're I definitely see
your legs getting pushed up by the
ceiling fan listen listen I think I'll
do both ways thank you open my Japanese
just watch at all just watch the [ __ ]
eyes greenie that's true if you're if
you're gay and you're getting [ __ ] do
you also have a boner like are you
turned off won't you I don't think you
do I've done enough research it probably
won't like verify that because if you
are it looks like would you put a guy in
[ __ ] and also jack off at the same
time no why not
no I don't that's what a reach-around is
right the guy reaches around in jerks
jerks you are you think well yeah that's
a real dish a B you get pegged huh it's
a pegging move you get pegged good
wouldn't it be how's that I'm blowing I
don't I just never I've never even
stretch that well down this rabbit hole
before this is my first time having this
time
so stream it I heard that there's a male
g-spot inside the booty ho that makes
guys come fast but I don't want to
discover each other at the same time is
that possible show me how how does it
happen
it's like this this was my dick would
get broke trying to fit behind so like
this right
it's like IKEA furniture not sometimes
you have a hole in the stickleton
pleasure room
I wish girls never got that [ __ ]
Seventeen magazine because every single
girlfriend I had when I was like 15 16
17 try to put fingers in my butt oh yeah
yeah but they always do that
tricks 52 trick to do to your man and
then these chicks would read this [ __ ]
and be like Oh sneak a little sound like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah yeah that's the
conversation y'all should have before
the barrel is even into it I never like
don't ever touch anything below my tank
and don't ever touch my nipples how do
you even bring that up in a regular
conversation none of that [ __ ] I wish I
could have my nipple surgically removing
it just be like oh no this does nothing
it would be the equivalent of somebody
sucking my wrist but you like that I'm
like are you telling me you never had a
second no I look you in the eyes I
shouldn't even look to you in there
that's what she say it's the problem no
because I already I already have
predisposed that I like to hear and so
then I was ready to let I was already
ready yeah that's the problem when we
got somebody there I don't care that
much about it's like try to [ __ ] with
the mole how are you with your belly
button cuz some guys are weird about
their my belly button has no ending so
it's weird I never got some people have
like a little swirl inside mine just
goes you're [ __ ] around you reach the
back of my [ __ ] before you test
something yeah like it's like a
little--yeah
you could just
going about yo this is weird that's an
emergency Idol is weird for me like I
was born there comes out of your ass
just sex what is the vacuum effect
you're like a human Pez I know I love it
but it's not weird cuz like I don't know
if it's you are too but like my
bellybutton is sensitive if you're not
like careful like we stick something in
there too far like my mommy I give out a
little bit you have a claimed your
bellybutton too hard and like you in the
shower and almost passed out I know
exactly we're talking about
I guess this weighs like a weird fill
it's like uh it's like a tingly yes I
got anything like this the only view
ever happens if I die pulling random
lint out or something how deep is your
belly but is this lovely random like
piece of cotton okay what's that [ __ ]
will you put a needle in here and you
feel it over here it's like that with
your bellybutton
yeah that like the static feeling like
you you like almost like when your legs
fall asleep but like when you first know
they fell asleep Nene black but it's
like a quick flash jolt yeah yes like
will you bang your elbow that said you
get the same like fill it yeah did you
guys all into 27 hours no no that James
Franco yeah J forego you saw that right
remember when he was about to do it to
the arm and it's the noise that they
made like like that it was so it was
that's what that that feeling is but
like just that's the sound of that
feeling absolutely do not love it that's
just weird
that's it oh why would I love almost
past enough
that's your phase right good like though
that was [ __ ]
just try to put some things on point out
too I was here in December January was
the December December happy near you
have to get the invite from bar it to
the gym I don't wanna bring that out I
want to lose weight I want to be a
better human Marcus and I just like yo
like I don't want to just pull up like
yo what's up boy I'm all right I know
right now okay I think you know what
you're getting yourself into but you
didn't want to do that I don't even want
to be twice don't do this like that's
how I got addicted to coke but what I'm
trying to say I want to be a better
person
good for you just say just know that
this whole room is gonna say a prayer
for you this is why we've known them for
years and we don't work out with them
yeah what am i ugly side trainer for six
months in it you and you smash [ __ ]
six squatted 135 hos really you lasted
six months with that that's [ __ ]
amazing
yeah Eddie ran you say you were like
five miles you say that's just
disgusting we're running 13 this
Saturday okay if I go 13 no 13 is that
god that's like go 13 miles yeah this
guy's so fun that one of his goals this
year is running
that's just so [ __ ] weird wish I was
one of those people that just like good
like I don't be without like run and
they spaced out like my wife she could
wear like yeah just like what a [ __ ]
that's what I said long disses in
cross-country track and she let you go
comment like but no I'm not coming to
your track me so boy she's just seeking
this black option listen music and she
just right it's very meditative actually
you get in like this flow state and you
just kind of just chill and you kind of
get to have all these thoughts to
yourself and your body to startle you so
crazy because like well honey just
starts moving on its own and you're not
even like propelling it anymore just
doing it yeah I could do that in a
recliner say the same thing about
killing people what I could do that
liner yeah no you're right though the
Sira killers talk exactly in that same
to testify it's fine you won't be
legally allowed yeah you can't yeah you
can't testify against your wife or
husband even if you're a if your wife
hates you boy so she renounces the
marriage since she can but like if you
guys are still technically married it is
a good Union it's not like if he
assaults you you can't do it it's more
like it has to do the outside parties
yeah unless I love it like if you see
subpoena to I don't know if there's a
it's the Bonnie and Clyde rule I don't
know she literally texts me I was like
hey I can't wait to see you guys she hit
me up was a Instagram we were talking
about the video she's a gay gonna be
with us this week I was like yeah I
can't wait she was like this I was like
cool she was like that's my prayer hands
I'm scheming on you that's like what the
[ __ ] who thinks like that me now I can't
wait to do it to somebody else Robin
hands that's pretty good that's what
it's supposed to be gonna bring up
everything looks like you're an emoji
guy are you an emoji guy um literally
only in my comments on like Instagram
okay because it's sometimes easy just to
type in that this the laughing side face
versus you know what I like now is go be
be AWA JJ - like those sideways eyes now
I like those which one oh yeah did like
drama Tommy on those yeah yeah all that
right just the eyes this table up yeah I
like I like the rolling eyes like this
like I do that to everything class I
like the hmm well you ever really said
it when you send it you really like I'm
taking it okay mm-hmm yeah wonder
whatever whatever
yeah how was the Czech Republic it was
amazing yeah how do you had carpaccio
I couldn't Silas I probably don't eat it
it's really tart are are you supposed to
eat that oh yeah it's [ __ ] good man
like medium
oh yeah I've never I've never been eaten
or Singh at a table somebody that got
rare like medium-rare I've never seen I
went to a mean house and they have all
kinds of hole cut meats it's just like
salami Xand [ __ ] all this [ __ ] and
you just you get you know a big board
full of meats mmm and then they just
stack on a [ __ ] big thing of breads
and you just sit there and go to town
mr. Kirk Kirk you read damn it I was
hoping someone would say it's I know how
to [ __ ] say it out loud yeah I don't
know if I'm right still really there's
no way it's so good week right we stop
with water my row but I was like what is
this boy I was just point to it so wait
like this so it was no exotic meat you
just like regular like salami pepperoni
good night like that right Oh cuz I feel
like all over Europe the food is pretty
much similar it's just a little bit
different in style okay yeah and I was
just kind of shocked because it was like
raw meat yeah we just can we get all
over the bread Ethiopian food where's
just chunks of raw meat chunk yeah like
what yeah it's crazy
I have math coach and I'ma be honest
with you guys I would walk in that
resume like this [ __ ] is dumb they would
ask me to leave the other stuff is like
salami and whatever but is that cook of
this cure it scared me a little cook on
it just a little cook on it like Syria
to something like sushi yeah pepperoni
like if it's not cooked a pepperoni when
it's not cooked like you don't get the
crackers and cheese and you you eat the
pepper a pepperoni on my pizza do it
that's good but have you ever had a
Robin Anna like just fresh off the tree
uncooked banana ungood what is what do
you cook you cook everything in his own
hot plate you heard him hook your Ritz
crackers I mean they're already cooked
they're baked at the Roberts listen he
goes to your fruit stand and he plugs
his hot plate into the wall and he
[ __ ] cook supper
okay pal I know what's good if people
have none I told this on another podcast
I used to put kool-aid and my pancake
mix this is I didn't I didn't have like
like Geoffrey I mean like huge eyes it
was like I'm making with flour eggs
water and put some sugar in it and then
I would put like the rear pack of
kool-aid in there for taster color yeah
let me tell you why because if you just
put the kool-aid in you're depending on
the syrup to make it sweet and it's not
gonna be good you have to put some sugar
in there and that batter and whip it up
it's called first of all you don't smell
fantastic upon charging great what the
best flavors I tried and you put a
little sup on there but you don't need a
whole lot cuz they're already flavorful
it's gonna be fired I promise you just
try one is it red are they bright red
paint they were bright red guys you they
were [ __ ] late but I did that when I
was like 14 so why do you want us to try
our oldest [ __ ] try it okay time you
have a kid he would love it his friends
about it oh he would my kid yeah 14 oh
[ __ ] yeah she's not really kidding well
I'm just counting down the [ __ ] basis
she's out of there
four more years man [ __ ] out there
actually we tried to get her masturbated
next on her 16th birthday because she
has a different day and we can't get in
contact with this dick here so I can't
take her out of the country like we
going on these places I really wanted
her to experience that boy get him to
like we don't know where the [ __ ] he is
and this family is completely
unresponsive to us so we can hurry
emancipated at 16 so she can get her own
passport she could sign for herself I
did also like that way if she get a tool
with me you'll get the [ __ ] out right
that's why that's how it started I
thought you're like we're good I'm
separating emancipated in two years I
want it sound that way I mean they're
getting a matte spit out of the kind of
your own heart it's pretty cool yeah
yeah yeah what is the balance to it this
is the force is literally a force and a
dark side but if you [ __ ] up you're out
yeah there's a vacation but if you [ __ ]
up I'm leaving you here
yeah figure it out in the Czech Republic
[ __ ] raw meat this is my favorite
question I asked comedians with kids
does your kid think you're [ __ ] one
no oh yes yes
which is it you could never be a dad and
be cool enough Yeah right she thinks her
mom is way she deals with mom is way
funnier than me I'm sure but but she is
so at home I'm off like in my comfort
zone I'm a [ __ ] hermit like I just
sit back and I watch them they make me
laugh I don't have to do because I have
to be at the bathrooms so yeah her mom
they just started a podcast sooo yeah
it's called a house school today and
they just talk about working school it's
time yes I gonna have you on I was how
you can't afford like five to ten
episodes there cuz I can pop remote
right now it's not gonna help you like
so many girls here pages in one episode
then they're gonna come back so let's
build it up a little bit and then talk
to my age you gotta know what your
audiences do like what are they going
for like that's the thing my little
brothers wants to do family vlogs and
like if any of us was to promote it it's
like that's not the audience yeah it's
not it's really that's true that's
another thing because I'm telling her
like you could she could be clean on
YouTube like now they have the whole for
kids content that type of stuff and I
was like you could if you do that mr.
gills big you can get a ton more
sponsors and advertisers then I can
because I'm not gonna be clean and she
was like I don't give a [ __ ] about that
I just want to be able to have fun with
my kid and I was like it's my [ __ ]
love you're a lad you bow people get
notice when you're in it for the money
they known as quickly yeah absolutely
immediately destroy okay I get it yeah I
get money I feel like it's gonna come
like we were talking about outside like
money is freedom financial freedom is
the ability to be on vacation right [ __ ]
I wish we could stay one more day or two
more days but you got to get back to
work cuz you can't say yeah but they
find out you're you like you know what
let's take another week right I'm going
to Vegas be like how much is this like
that's you know like you know Vegas is
gonna be inherently expensive but if you
like got to find out your freedom you
just like give me two steaks cooked
go away it's a Julia Roberts movie Eat
Pray Love she's like I'll have another
pizza ah nice I never saw it well you
can see pretty much I just feel like it
was over white and I was like I
yeah best guy white friend the one who
needed a buddy the CVT pay love with
that's a jelly you were already taken
care of what I get to know
[Music]
[Music]